the story goes when gas is just a little
little boy like you know I don't know
early primary school he had a really
lazy teacher who just wanted his
students unbelievable money okay so the
lazy teacher said to the whole class he
said okay look uh here's a task for you
we're gonna do some mathematics today I
want you to add up the numbers one to a
hundred
it didn't come back to me when you're
finished right so so students most of
them excited dutifully working out of
partial sums they said ok 1 + 2 3 3 plus
3 6 the next one will be 10 by the way 1
3 6 10 the next was giving 15 they are
also important in this but it's beside
the point and they were suitably you
know occupied but of course Gauss Gauss
came up within seconds and said oh it's
okay beyond the sum of all of these is
5050 said it without batting an eyelid
to reach the least lazy teacher which
you know obviously suitably upset
because they thought oh I had a great
task to do this for a while and it
failed now how did he get his answer so
rapidly and so efficiently well he used
a technique which I am going to teach
you today in you 12 ok here's what he
does I'll actually going to because -
you guys a little bit of dignity we're
going to tackle a problem with a
slightly larger then what gauss was
going to do so instead of this problem
which is very specific and it just has
an answer
i want to consider this problem one plus
two plus three plus then another i want
to end rather than 100 terms i want to
end because we've been talking about
partial sums up to the nth term i want
to end and at it okay sir I'm just going
to write a few extra terms that balance
and that okay so this is this is the
song up to the editor okay now just
before I do anything here I want to
point out to you what I was talking
about before remember I showed you the
alternating harmonic series and I showed
you it um was a bit dangerous right what
we're mucking around with there was this
law here this one day I've written at
the top this is what we call the Lord
commute activity because addition is
what we call come you take two you can
switch the order it's okay but you can
only switch the order in certain cases
you'll notice this only takes a pair of
numbers a pair of numbers right if what
you have is a infinite string of numbers
okay the Sun is sometimes actually the
same if you rearrange but often white be
example I showed you before it is not
okay so just want to point out the
danger happens with infinity right there
are lots of reasons why infinity is a
dangerous thing I can keep we go to
Alberta spruce later on well surprise to
say when you have a look at this is this
in the first category or the second
category is that the first category the
second category what makes the second
category the second category is that
yeah well more specifically it doesn't
end right the fact that it doesn't end
is what makes it dicey okay now this is
an indeterminate way but it does finish
it's got an endpoint okay so therefore I
can rearrange through my heart's to life
and new rules of the universe we
violated okay the reason why that's
important is because here is essentially
what gauss did right i could actually do
it here on him on his secrets right
what he did there every clever trick is
he took his terms and he realized this
is the color I want
he realized that because it's an AP we
want so many words because an AP it had
this marvelous symmetry to it do you see
it has symmetry right as times increase
from the left going to the right they
decrease going for the right to the left
that makes sense doesn't it
not only does an increase in decrease
they increase a decrease at the same
rate and that's crucial reason why it's
crucial is because I can do some pairing
feel right I can take the first term and
the last term I can add them together
give me a sum in this case up a drum one
and I can look at the second term and
the second last term and because they
grow and shrink at the same rate because
all a please do this pen will also add
up to 101 okay now all the pairs are
that's 101 how many pairs are there
there are 50 pairs because if n is 100
right I have that and then I get the
number of pairs which is 50 50 times 101
what gives you this answer okay
now is the interesting Gina um what
happens if I can't pair up because I
can't pair up every single sequence is
out there I only get to coincidentally
pair this thing up because it has an
even number of terms okay so for
instance if I considered this very very
similar no I'm just gonna stop there now
thankfully because I know what s of a
hundred years and I know what sorry I
know what this hundred is and I know
what ti Madrid is it's pretty easy to
work out what smle nineties isn't it
which is what this popped off I just
have to take the difference no big deal
but how am I gonna use my Perry thing
here
here's how I'm going to do it I don't
have cares if I have an odd number of
numbers so the easiest way to make an
odd number of numbers is 2 so I make it
even is to double it alright that will
give me an even number of numbers right
here's where I'm going to invoke this
it's kind of important right
the pairing worked because we pan up the
first and the last the second the second
last and so on so I'm gonna do the same
thing here if I've doubled it I could
write it in the same order but it will
be more useful to sue me if I write it
in Reverse
do you see what let's do it I'm gonna
end there I'm gonna have n minus 1 and
minus 2 there which pair which terminal
match up with n minus 3 on this end
it'll be the third last second must last
so this should be green right
and this should be true this should be 1
now I have my magical cares right and
they still do the same thing and then
now in Gauss's case they would still add
up to 101 in our case our generalized
case right what does each pair add up to
n plus 1 and n plus 1 and n plus 1
now how many n plus non-embedded what
but they get on the right hand side how
many n plus ones do I have I have n of
them don't I because i double I double
the number of terms in this series right
there's n terms on this line but if I
take both lines cause they're paired
there'll be to it right so all the way
up until
the enth Perry right but of course I've
got twice as many things as I want right
so me that there n pairs that are n plus
one in size but I don't want double
being partial sum I just want the other
partial sum I divide
okay so Gauss's case was for N equals
100 but I can do it for anything and you
can see that my second method doesn't
rely on there being an even number of
terms right like I did here I'm going to
match up with a different sequence and
it will work all right
no last little bit I know the bells not
to go I'll let you think about this in
the context of an AP right this is a
particular a page
what about any AP okay watch with me I
say that what I've got here is a sum of
terms right the first term and then
what's the next term in an AP any AP
ain't plus the common difference right
and then a plus shoe lots of the common
difference now in gas the situation he
had the last term and in a in a tragedy
of naming consistency the first term is
a and the last term should be should be
Z because that's the last min of the
alphabet but unfortunately they were
like Oh analyst for lost let's make it L
even there a is not the first better
whatever now that's the last term
what's the month preceding to think
preceding preceding it's L minus the
clothing difference right so now if I do
my carry I'm gonna take a bit of a
shortcut
how big is each pen what's the size of
each pay when I combine it sometimes
you're watching it's a equals L right
how many of these pants do I have
Elle is the value of the last tour but n
is how many turns I have one more line I
promise okay for a sum of n terms in an
AP I actually know what the internees
don't I I am a formula for this guy
what's the formula for the nth term it's
a plot how many lots of the common
difference minus one so if I put that in
instead I have this and on true how many
aids are there inside the brackets is
that one and there's this one today and
then I've got n minus one lots of their
common difference yeah